hello grammarians hello paige hi david
so today we're going to tackle
this idea of what is a sentence
yeah as we go into this realm of
language that is called
syntax
and syntax is this concept of basically
grammatical order what this this word
syntaxis literally means in greek is uh
you know putting together and arranging
right so it just
means ordering of language
so that's like what a sentence is that's
what a sentence is that's what a
sentence is it's what the components of
a sentence are and we'll go into all of
that in much greater detail but in order
to do that first of all we have to
figure out
what a sentence actually is so the the
definition that you and i came up with
page is that a sentence is a
grammatically complete idea
right
it's a bunch of words
that say one
one complete thing so all sentences have
a noun or pronoun component right and
that's what we call the subject
and then we have the verb part which is
the the predicate
so a sentence has it has to have like a
thing or a noun or a pronoun sure that's
the subject yeah and and something that
it's doing sure that's the predicate
yeah okay so let's say we've got this
sentence
the great big dog
licked my face
here is our sentence what is the subject
subject is the great big dog all right
and that means that everything that's
not the subject is part of the predicate
right
so licked my face is the predicate so
this is the noun chunk
that is performing the action of the
sentence you got it cool
so all sentences have to have this right
yeah they have to have
a subject and a predicate these two
separate parts
so if you said if you asked a question
like
are you named david
okay if you ask that of me
which go ahead are you named david i am
is this a sentence it's really short it
is very short but
you see i is a pronoun okay so that can
be the subject that's our subject and m
is a verb
so
it has a subject and a predicate so this
is the noun or pronoun part and this is
the action that it is performing
although am or being isn't really an
action it's more of a linking verb sure
um
but it's still a verb
okay so this is this is the predicate
then for sure yeah
okay so
but paige
let's say
i dropped a muffin right
uh and you told me
pick up that muffin
that sentence doesn't seem to have so
let me write that down
that sentence doesn't seem to have a
subject i see how all of this
is predicate right pick up is a verb and
then and then the muffin is the thing
that's being picked up like that's all
one thing where's
what goes in the blue box i see so when
we have a sentence like this where i'm
telling you to do something
there doesn't always have to be
a subject said out loud okay this is
this is like an order right i'm telling
you you have to pick up that muffin so
this is kind of like an invisible
secret subject right and this subject
really is you you pick up that muffin
but i don't have to say it out loud
because i know that you're talking to me
because i can tell because you're
looking at me and you're yelling at me
about a muffin yes i am so a sentence is
a grammatically complete
idea
or expression
and it has to have a noun a pronoun part
which we call the subject
and it has to have a verb and all its
baggage part which is what we call the
predicate
and sometimes that subject can sort of
be implied or invisible as in the
command pick up that muffin right cool
you can learn anything dave it out page
out